my family everyone in my family is  absolutely massive and I mean I look at  a packet of crisps and I put on like  five kilos like my metabolism but I make  conscious decisions and I mean I reckon  if I lived in Poland I'd probably be  stick thin I probably would it wouldn't  you know be going to the gym and trying  to grow my legs and so forth I'd be  trying to be as skinny as possible but  you know I chose a partner that's in the  gym industry and he teaches me certain  things other things I'll Google myself  because he can't teach me about you know  woman's nutrition it's it's all about  accountability and making your own  choices  [Music]